Speaker 1: The David Pakman Show is an audience
supported program. We have a membership program.
It is completely cool and completely legal.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money.
Speaker 3: And everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And you can sign up at join
pacman dot com. You can use the coupon
code big voting 22 to get a discount.
Let's start calls via discord. We take phone
calls at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
They're not really phones, but you know, we still
call them phone calls. Let's start today with our
friendly neighbors to the north. Going to ya'll
from Ontario is this Ontario, Canada, ya'll?
Oh, boy. Ya'll. If you unmute,
I'll be able to hear you.
Ya'll from Ontario. Last chance. An
inauspicious start today. That is disappointing.
Let's go to Mark from Los Angeles.
Mark, I'm confident you'll save us.
Speaker 3: Hello. Hello.
Speaker 1: You're on the air. Yes.
Speaker 3: Oh, awesome. Fantastic.
I love your show. First of all,
I just want to I mean, you people have already
said this, but have you seen more signs that
that the abortion issue is actually going might
shift the needle in terms of the midterms? Yes.
Speaker 1: Yes, I have.
Speaker 3: Because I yeah. Because the funny thing
is, I was I work with a lot of folks that like,
you know, blue collar, a lot of conservatives.
And one of the things that they don't seem to
realize is I actually know a woman who is a born
again Christian. She's a relative of mine who
is fervently pro abortion. She actually had one
and she's unapologetic. It's kind of shocking
when you talk to so you don't realize how many
people are actually in favor of their rights to be
able to do what they want to do with their bodies.
That's that's one thing I just wanted to say is,
you know, I think this might be a big touchstone,
a shock wave that might might overtake the
next election, because it's just it's something
it's one thing when it's ambiguous, but when
someone when they take something away from you,
you realize you wake up, you know, and.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so two things on that.
Number one, more of the country is in favor of
abortion being legal in most cases than at any
time during the Roe v Wade era. So and that's
exactly why, as Mark points out, there's even
Born Again Christians or whatever who are in favor
of individuals having that right. And secondly,
every generic ballot poll that I have seen this
week shows Democrats now leading where three
months ago Democrats were losing. So I do think,
Mark, that Democrats have a shot thanks to what's
going on with Roe v Wade and thanks to what's
going on with the lack of gun safety regulation.
Speaker 3: Oh, that's fantastic. Oh, and also,
I wanted to say congratulations. I mean, the
funny thing is, I dip out. I do actually take your
advice. I dip out of politics sometimes because it
becomes so toxic that I can't take it anymore. And
I stop listening to you. I'm a I'm a subscriber,
by the way. Thank you. But I just. I take
a break for, like, a week or so, and I came
back and all of a sudden you had a baby.
Speaker 1: Listen, I was shocked. I all of
a sudden came back and I had a baby. If
you think you were shocked to hear it,
I was shocked to be doing it. You know, Mark.
Speaker 3: Wait. Is this one of those like.
She didn't know she was pregnant. No, no.
Speaker 1: It is not. It is nothing like
that. It's just still that shocking.
Speaker 3: Oh. Okay. Okay. Well,
yeah. I remember watching a gynecologist say that
one of the most amazing things about her job is
she never gets over the fact that she walks in
the room. And then by the time they're finished,
there's an extra person in the world.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, try going to
the hospital with two people and coming
out with three. It's quite a shocker.
Speaker 3: Well, I want to congratulate you, Dave.
Oh, and one last thing I want to say is that, you
know, I work as a stagehand. And one of the things
that I never could get is, remember the whole
voting rights bills that, you know, that failed.
Yes. You know, well, I worked on the Super Bowl.
And like the the person who sung The Star-Spangled
Banner is black. I'm African-American is black.
The person who sang the national anthem is black.
The overwhelming majority of the football members
are black. And I'm just like standing here, like
like working. I'm just like, why can't we? We
need to, like, just, like, do a protest. Do like,
what's that famous Greek play where all the women
wouldn't have sex with the men, and so they stop
the war. We just, like, protest or something or
get active in order to try to force these people.
Cause there's that is a $5 billion event. One of
black folks said and you know what? We yes
yes I was shocked to is a five so far stadium
that that thing in terms of like all the money
that's made off of the Super Bowl it's $5 billion.
Speaker 1: I got mark it's quite a number. Listen,
Mark, you've said it all. I'm going to let you go.
I look forward to hearing from you again. Okay.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thanks a lot. All right.
Speaker 1: Mark shot out of a cannon
today on fire. Completely on fire. Okay.